[موسيقى]
افتتاح مونديال 2002 و20 حفل استثنائي
بهويه عربيه ولماذا الغي هدف الاكوادور في
قطر اعلان ميسي ورونالدو يثير الجدل على
السوشيال ميديا هذه الاخبار وغيرها
تتابعونها من العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
لاول مره في التاريخ برزت الصبغه العربيه
في منافسات كاس العالم المقامه حاليا في
قطر بدا من مشاركه رؤساء وقاده الدول
العربيه في مقدمتهم الامير محمد بن سلمان
ولي العهد السعودي والرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي ورئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس
بجانب انفنتينو رئيس الاتحاد الدولي لكره
القدم ثم استاد البيت الذي توحي تصميمه من
الخيبه التي يسكنها اهل الباديه وترتبط
بكلام ضيافه
ونبقى مع حفل افتتاح المونديال حيث تصدر
نجم العالمي موردين مع الشاب القطري غانم
المفتاح في اولى فقرات حفل افتتاح كاس
العالم 2022 اخبار السوشيال ميديا الحفل
بدا برساله انسانيه من الممثل الامريكي
القدير ثم ظهرت طفل غانم المفتاح وقام
بقراءه ايه من القران الكريم وبعد ذلك
طلقت مرامس مراسم الحفل بظهور الجمال ثم
فقط غنائيه قطريه تعبر عن الهويه العربيه
وسط العاب الليزر
معدوده من انطلاق المنافسات العالميه
وحدثت حاله جدليه بعدما الغت التقنيات
الفيديو هدفا لمنتخب الاكوادور في شباك
قطر بدعه تسلل الجدول يثير هل التسلل صحيح
على الاكوادور ام لا الاعاده التلفزيونيه
اظهرت ان اللاعب كان متسللا بامتار قليله
بعد لعب الركله الحره التي اتامنها الهدف
ويعود الفضل في ذلك الى تقنيه التسلل شبه
الاوتوماتيكيه او التسلل نصف الالي التي
تطبق للمره الاولى في مونديال هذه المره
في مونديال قطر
في المغرب اقدم الشركات الخاصه على تغيير
توقيت عملها خلال الايام التي ستقام فيها
مباريات المنتخب الاول في مونديال قطر
الخاصه ستمنح اذن المغادره لكل من يرغب في
متابعه مباريات المنتخب المغربي والرجوع
بعد انتهاء المباراه من اجل استئناف العمل
وفي ذات السياق قررت ايضا بعض مؤسسات
التعليم الخاص تثبيته شاشه التلفاز بداخل
المؤسسات من اجل تمكين التلاميذ من متابعه
مباريات المنتخب المغربي دون الاضرار الى
التغيب عن المدارس
الختام مع ثنائي الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي
والبرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو اللذين اثر
الجدل ايضا اعسوشيال ميديا قبل ساعات من
بدء منافسات كاس العالم اللاعبان شاركا في
اعلان تجاري ل 11 شركات الازياء المربوقه
عالميه وذلك في صوره جمعتهما معا وقام كل
منهما بنشرها عبر حساباته بمواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي هذا الاعلان التاريخي استطاع
جذب انظار العالم حوله خاصه انه الاول
الذي يجمع رونالدو وميسي معا بعد مسيره
التنافسيه قاربت على عقدين من السماء
[موسيقى]